an army patrol at chitwan national park
the soldiers are on the lookout for
illegal fishermen and poachers but they
keep an eye on the crocodiles the
long-nosed girls are threatened with
extinction their eggs are often stolen
from their nests chitwan national park
extends over a thousand square
kilometers it's one of the largest
protected areas in Nepal waiting for a
Bengal tiger the lord of the jungle is
there even if he seldom shows himself
camera traps supply the evidence
worldwide of the mere 3,000 Tigers still
living in the wild the good 120 of them
live in chitwan biologist ashish
adhikari says the number is growing the
habitat that is still we do have that is
sufficient for building the tiger means
this nipple can achieve doubling the
tiger according to official accounts in
2014 Paul lost no big game to poaching
the country is considered an
international role model for species
protection success first came to the
mass deployment of the army as here in
chitwan where every day about 1,500
soldiers searched the park for poachers
smart patrolling mobile phones with GPS
record what areas are searched and when
species protection in the National Park
works only because people in the
surrounding villages also benefit from
it
for instance from the more than 100,000
tourists hoping to get a picture of a
one horned rhinoceros half of the
entrance fee goes to the local
population that pays off villagers often
help the soldiers these field workers
have discovered and reported illegal
fishermen a tip-off has led to this man
being captured he's accused of having
killed 22 rhinos over the last year's
rhinoceros horn sells for about fifty
thousand euros a kilo in China as a
treatment for impotence and cancer now
the alleged poacher faces 15 years in
prison but Nepal's most dangerous
elephant is still at large even though
he said to have killed 21 people the
mood is tense even among the soldiers
Derby is like a ghost that disappears
for a long time then turns up again
species protection expert do a Garchomp
again from WWF Nepal can only speculate
as to why the elephant became so
dangerous so lovely to add the hum by
some people otherwise unless and until
it was like a hum by any people it will
not generally attack for three years
durba has behaved himself soldiers will
no longer shoot at him as long as he
remains peaceful it's the nicest way for
the army to protect Nepal's animals
through non-violence